jetzt mal wirklich mal gute nachrichten
die internetplattform abgeordnetenwatch
hat vor gericht gerade durchgesetzt dass
der deutsche bundestag seine unterlagen
zur parteienfinanzierung veröffentlichen
muss eine bittere niederlage für
wolfgang schäuble der als hausherr die
sache mit den parteispenden überwacht
ausgerechnet schäuble gehört doch selber
war ein briefumschlag mit schwarzgeld
naja jagd dass ich halt selber ist mal
was anderes und er geht wohl in berufung
weil er die akten nicht rausrücken will
heißt es
dabei haben wir doch in deutschland seit
2006 das informationsfreiheitsgesetz
demnach haben wir bürger ein recht auf
akteneinsicht
es geht also voran wenn auch langsam es
gibt drei bundesländern die noch kein
informationsfreiheitsgesetz haben
sachsen niedersachsen und natürlich auch
bayern hessen hat jetzt endlich eins
bekommen durch die schwarz grüne
regierung allerdings ist das das
schlechteste informationsfreiheitsgesetz
in deutschland weil so gut wie alle
behörden in hessen ausgenommen sind
davon wie praktisch oder übrigens unter
frag den staat de leite names and
thought ja es ist der bruder arne selbst
und seine kollegen bürger fragen gerne
an den staat weiter denn transparenz
wäre doch das beste mittel gegen die da
oben gelaber leider möchten manche aber
gar nicht transparent seien
die csu in bayern zum beispiel wehrt
sich seit 15 jahren erfolgreich gegen so
ein gesetz
ich habe auch nicht den eindruck dass
der durchschnittsbürger akten wälzen
will ich könnte dem sonst würde ja
gerade die normalbürger er überfordern
ich kann da nämlich 100 aktenordner hin
schieben und was macht denn der einfache
bürger damit kann er gar nicht anfahren
der einfache bürger ist so doof der weiß
gar nicht wie man so eine akte aufklappt
wird
[Applaus]
einfache bürger
der einfache bürger der solo auf der wg
csu also manche
es dauert aber nicht nur bayern auf
bundes und landesebene setzt der staat
immer noch auf das prinzip abschreckung
wenn bürger fragen haben wichtigste
abschreckungs waffe gebühren
da werden dann schon mal für ein
dokument 500 euro aufgerufen in bayern
wollten journalisten zb mal was zum
salmonellen skandal ist auf unseren
antrag heißt es wegen der zahlreichen
unterlagen ergebe sich allein für die
sichtung eine geschätzte gebühr von
circa 24.000 750 euro ein schnäppchen
freuen
ausgerechnet bayern das sich gerade
dieses neue big brother polizeigesetz
gibt claire seiner bürger gern gläserner
start um gottes willen so behörden haben
hat auch gern ihre ruhe
naja ist ja klar altes deutsches
obrigkeitsdenken der untertan soll sich
raushalten gefälligst und zu viel lesen
machte kopfschmerzen
lieber bürger deutschland ist schön
deutschland geht es gut und das siegen
muss man in deutschland auch gar nicht
ständig vertrauliche akten lesen
vertrau uns wenn wir sagen es gibt hier
nichts zu sehen
es gibt hier absolut nichts zu sehen
und wenn doch willst du es gar nicht
wissen
diese antworten würde die bevölkerung
verunsichern
in diesem sarg liegt ich lieber hinein
bundesregierung weiter
wissen sie wahrscheinlich gar nicht
tatsächlich gibt es in einem keller
unter dem kanzleramt in berlin ein
spezielles archiv in dem tina hausten
die geheimsten geheimakten der
bundesregierung verwaltet china wie
viele bürger anfragen kommen denn so
rein nach dem
informationsfreiheitsgesetz das ist der
wahnsinn oliver der blanke horror
im letzten jahr hatten wir zwölf 1950
bürgeranfragen bei bundesbehörden ein
anstieg um 40
vielen dank idioten dürfen mich alles
dran gesetzt wissen die leute eigentlich
dass wir nebenbei auch noch was anderes
zu tun haben regieren zb was fragen sie
denn so das kann ich ihnen sagen nur
schwachsinn wann wird der berliner
flughafen fertig wenn er fertig ist
was futterkosten viel was macht
alexander dobrindt beruflich zwei ska
nach
die die frage oben arbeiten beim
verfassungsschutz auch leute die keine
nazis sind
nein ich habe keinen bock mehr ich habe
mir jetzt einfach einen satz
standard-antwort stempel besorgt und
feierabend keine ahnung
fragt ein friseur leck mich deine angela
sollte man nicht froh sein dass die
bürger sich wieder mehr für politik
interessieren für die wahrheit hinter
den fakten die bürger die können doch
mit der wahrheit nicht umgehen die
können sie nicht vertragen
oliver hier liegen geheimnisse die
dürfen nie ans licht kommen
die spender denen helmut kohl damals
sein ehrenwort gegeben hat wenn jemals
rauskommt dass der uli hoeneß dabei war
oder hier wie der bnd aus versehen john
f kennedy erschossen hat sie wollten
eigentlich chatten treffen
das freundschaftsbuch von jens spahn aus
der vierten klasse komplett leer
[Applaus]
dass das brisanteste geheimnis überhaupt
der richtige vornahme von bernd löcke er
heißt das muss
[Applaus]
es ist
es ist ganz ganz lange geschichte ab das
sieht doch alles olle kamellen mal was
aktuell ist jetzt kam raus das
verkehrsministerium hat monatelang ein
diesel gutachten unter verschluss
gehalten indem drinsteht hardware
nachrüstung werden die lösung und zwar
noch immer das gegenteil erzählt moment
in sachen diesen haben wir immer alles
sofort raus gegeben
wissen sie noch die akten vom
kraftfahrtbundesamt da stand doch alles
drin was sie als bürger wissen müssen
die haben wir mit diesel ruß geschwärzte
einfach drei sekunden von passat aus
prof
das ist doch alles albern demnächst
zwingt euch das bundesverwaltungsgericht
in leipzig alles zum thema
parteienfinanzierung rauszurücken so was
macht man denn dann das kann ich ihnen
zeigen was ich dann mache wissen sie
bevor hier pins und kunst an meine akten
dürfen das gar keiner an meine akten das
ist ja mal klar dass alles meinem eine
meile
so und jetzt muss ich weiter arbeiten
[Applaus]